hallo leute wie sieht eure mal waren und
willkommen zu einem neuen video
ich war jetzt schon drei tage auf der
gamescom und auf der gamescom partys als
sie an meiner stimme hören könnt wenn
ich hoch spreche klingt das zur zeit und
ich würde ganz gerne wieder normal
sprechen aber das geht irgendwie nicht
ich versuche die ganze zeit er ich war
das erste mal auf der gamescom und da
gab es so eine cosplay merchandise dort
haben kelly und ich diese mystery typen
gefunden und schon eine im livestream
auf instagram war ja auch gemacht und
ich habe gedacht ich möchte unbedingt
hüten auspacken in einem video und habe
dafür drei tüten in drei verschiedenen
preiskategorien gekauft wollen wir
packen sie jetzt gemeinsam auch in der
kleinsten kategorie haben wir keine zehn
euro rosenweg in der mittleren kategorie
haben wir eine 25 euro my little pony
weg und in der 50 euro größten tüte
haben wir eine ich weiß was ihr jetzt
denkt das hat alles absolut nichts mit
dem zu tun was mir aber egal sind all
die dinge die mich im leben
interessieren und damit müsst ihr clark
und fangen an mit der rosenberg was er
dir eigentlich dass der zweite teil bald
rauskommt es wäre doch viel lustiger
wenn quads in der box schreiben würden
anstatt what can be in the box
ich bin gespannt welche tüte sich am
meisten lohnt und ob da vielleicht
einfach nur trash drin wendet ja da
haben wir unsere ersten träsch auf jeden
fall da was ist das überhaupt
keating ohne dich lieber urlaub
gehört das so ja ich habe den
komischsten von 1 um mein gott und ein
wolf aus marl bild also die tüte hat
sich jetzt schon gelohnt ist gut es ist
nicht meine nase und im wechsel und was
im hals supergeil
aber wie heißt noch mal das rentier das
ist ja sven rittau den finde ich
niedlich aber wie macht man den sound ok
exorzismus ist da das wird mein keller
schlüsselanhänger 10 euro und judith
[Musik]
spielern aus meint bilde ich raste aus
ich kenne wirklich genug 1000 fans den
ich das schon kann das hier mega süß
guck mal das wichtigste ist oder war
geil 14 findet eigentlich auch nicht so
schalten gesagt ich werde meine tüte
mich hatte das macht sie jetzt mit fall
ein video das ist gleich ich finde er
hat sich gelohnt werden euro für zehn
euro ist eine gute ausbeute hatte mir
bei 25 euro
da bin ich echt gespannt ich habe keine
ahnung was da drin sein soll
ich kann mir noch figuren vorstellen
jana also so für meine lippen
ich hoffe dass es so hart zeugen ok wenn
da was für die haben uns dann müssen wir
das heute auf diese partien ja egal wie
es aussieht 12
die erste bombe okay ist ein kleiner
gummi figur
aber welcher ist irgendwie passt auch
noch zu finden ist oder schon wieder
sagen alles schon irgendwie du so land
zu die taste bekommen skipass ab sah vor
dass schon mega geil ist voll fair das
ist schon cool sind schon kurios ist
dass ein rädchen platter filipponi
platte ja ich bin geschockt das ist aus
meiner person wie es wahrgenommen und
bewertet
das sehen wollte hat also nach der figur
überall so überzeugt sich nichts mehr
noch einen schlüsselanhänger und bühl
stickers ticker
[Musik]
ok bis jetzt bereit oh mein gott jetzt
kommt jetzt aber hat sich die beiden
ponys 25 euro gelohnt wie die kostet 15
euro zone ungefähr
also wenn man jetzt mega meinem pony fan
ist hast du zwei figuren besser und
mitchell bekommen schon geil kommt so
der größten tüte und zwar die 50 euro
das keine poster 804 steht da drauf ich
bin mal gespannt ob wir alle erkennen
im hintergrund von der sound war und
jutebeutel mit allen namen
wie es heißt es auf fische merger denkt
so mancher an dem die halt auch gar
nichts verdienen weil es fähig ist
probably für lkw-verkehr dass sie cool
aus die haben schon genug geld also
jetzt was alles noch ein top komplett
auch zu viel
wir müssen nachdenken 50 euro stimmen
muss echt 50 euro wert sein
wie geil alter ich werde mit 1000 toten
[Musik]
schönig intakter brustring qualität in
folge gut hammer war es noch richtig
schöne tasse
[Musik]
untersetzer mit allen unterschriften und
ich cool mit dem unterschriften das
mache ich mir auf meinen schreibtisch
mit meiner eigenen schreibtisch
[Musik]
einstimmen unter sind wie gute qualität
ich werde auf die qualität ist gut die
wand schon richten bis zum teureren ja
ist das schön
der nachteil das coole bild ausgewählte
sieht von coolen sachen kauft
osterkarten
die hänge ich mir alle an die wand ja
und das war's man darf noch eine sache
wenn sie dazu noch ein magnet
du musst mir die ganzen bilder ab 2 als
ich gesehen habe dass wieder das
angeschaut das wusste ich schon dass das
denn darunter setzen wollen wird aber
dann willst du auch wirklich
ich habe sowieso ein tolles geschenk mit
dir von einst haben aber 10 10
er war sehen das ist ja niemals 50 euro
werks kann mir keiner sagen was ist das
ist so hast du dir alles beim official
bts job hat es aussuchen können für 50
euro
ich muss 150 euro war auf jeden fall
werden deine reaktion sei direkt die bts
tüte 50 euro als reaktion und bezahlen
ich leg mich jetzt mit meinen bildern
wieder ins bett afrikas zu machen mobile
kommt etwas abgestaubt und da zieht sich
wieder
[Musik]
damit war es das für das video hobby
entscheidet doch wie sehr gute nacht
oder guten morgen was haben wir daraus
gelernt holt euch keine mystery boxen
denn das sind meistens mit terry boxen
[Musik]
ich bin euer horst vanessa und das war
wie gibt man sein geld für schrott kann
mir haben dankeschön